okay so back to discuss back to discuss
so so the fundamental thing that I
learned from Paul Rossum is to see us as
these amazing omnivores this is part of
our survival strategy even more than
other other Apes we are just brilliant
omnivores and we have the Omnivore's
Dilemma which is we've got to be
interested in all kinds of new stuff
we're not tied to any place we can roam
on to a whole new continent so we're
interested in stuff but stuff has all
kinds of toxins and microbes we have to
be careful about that stuff and so these
motives have to be in tension and this
is actually an interesting way to
understand the left-right difference you
have to have both motives but if so
imagine two siblings one of whom is set
more towards trying new stuff seeking
out new stuff and the other is a little
more fearful and more like whoa no let's
you know let's not try that let's stay
with what's tried-and-true
I mean that's progressivism and
conservative and that's the origins of
it and if you look at kids behavior at
the age of two or three it does predict
how they'll vote much later not hugely
but there is a clear prediction there so
so disgust is part of a regulatory
system about our engagement with the
world and whether we are just sort of
out there and you know we we seek out
variety and diversity we think diversity
is just a great thing or whether we want
a little more order structure
predictability conservatives are neater
then progressives if you take photos of
their rooms you know you can actually
you know cleanliness an organization you
can predict how they vote disgust it
turns out what's really cool about
disgust in modern politics is if you
look at all the different things that
we're fighting over especially in this
country are culture wars over you know
going back a few decades you know sex
drugs the flag immigration all of these
things I have a study with my colleagues
was led by Seneca Leyva in which we
asked all these cultural war attitudes
of people and we also had their scores
in the discuss scale but one of the
foundations of morality is sanctity
impurity and it relates to discuss what
we found is that if you know if you know
what people's left-right we're how they
place themselves on the left/right scale
you can pretty much predict where they
fall out on most cult
or attitudes except for those that load
on or implicate sanctity or purities
what I mean is flag-burning
okay do you think you know do you think
that people should have the right to
burn the American flag or the country's
flag as an expression as a political
action what do you think people just
give some answer not one to seven scale
and people on the right think you know
more like they say no people on the Left
of yes people are score high on loyalty
are more likely to say no people who
lower end it say yes and that's even
taking account of where they're on the
left/right dimension but here's the cool
thing it's only if you add in the purity
or sanctity thing that you can really
understand what people are doing because
some people see the flag not as just a
piece of cloth they see it as having
some innate essence some something
sacred about it which must be protected
and so so this is true they think of it
as a unifying Center exactly that's
right so if there's something sacred and
this is that this is the central piece
of my work around politics and morality
is the psychology of sanctity